soit par ici je suis pas agressif celle
qui m'agace depuis une réunion pour
n'importe quoi je me défonce église
c'est toi qui énervait d'accord nous on
her morning de foot alors je suis pas
lesbienne pour tandis qu'au mot [ __ ]
ça va c'est pourquoi des impôts à ses
comparables à leur coach national avec l
argent te dire je suis pas lesbienne
pour que le disque augmenter quand nous
partons mais tu trouve même une [ __ ] est
bien dormir chez moi à toi ton moulin
est le cul qu'on allait chercher
maintenant portes au début d'année à
défaut d'accord parce que ta meuf allait
aussi l'achat de louey à l'achat de
beauté mais pourquoi t'es allé dire à
thoune qui ont été dans des bars gay
bordel en plus tu lation to dubai world
ils vont débarquer pourquoi tu fais ça
qui suis je te dise on aller dans des
bars gay on dirait c'est la fin novembre
c'est la fin d'une [ __ ] tu me crois
que je laisse deviner que je groupe
d'échappés elle croit que j'ai maté son
cul mais je savais pas si je vais lui
demander calmement